the opening scene features a news
reporter guou who narrates about keki
zili the last virgin Wilderness of China
he explains that this high altitude
plane is the only remaining habitat of
the Tibetan Antelope turns out that from
the year 1985 poachers began hunting
antelopes for their fine wool which was
prized in foreign markets as a result
the number of antelopes plunged from 1
million to under 10,000 within a few
years in order to combat these poachers
of volunteer civilian Patrol was formed
in the year 1993 led by a retired
Tibetan army officer R Thai despite
poverty and the lack of any government
support Rai dedicates himself to
safeguarding the endangered Tibetan
Antelope from Extinction the patrol
seems to have been fighting Fierce
battles with the poachers which also
have grabbed the attention of the
outside world the battle has now become
so intense that the poachers even
murdered one of the patrol men in the
winter of 1996 in the aftermath of this
event guou is sent from Beijing to cover
the story in detail upon arriving at
Kiki zili he goes to meet Rai who is
currently at the sky burial of the
deceased Patrol member after the funeral
Rai approaches guou and asks about his
identity when he introduces himself as a
reporter Rai instantly dismisses him
showing no interest in giving interviews
however he changes his mind when guou
asserts that he might help him in his
mission declaring this place as a Nature
Reserve at midnight the patrol team
receives information about the Newfound
dead bodies of antelopes in the junai
lake as a result they all arm themselves
with their weapons and drive to the
specified location now that guou is
admitted into the patrol he is also
allowed to accompany them in the hunt
for the poachers assuming his role as
some sort of embedded journalist after
an entire day of driving they arrive at
buong Springs conservation station which
is guarded by a Patrol member a wang a
wang this man is Overjoyed to see the
team because he only occasionally gets
to meet people and spends most of his
time alone when guou expresses his
concern about the same one of the team
members reveals that they do not have
enough human resources to hire for this
job so a wang has been guarding the
station alone for 3 years the patrolling
team spends a night there dancing and
enjoying time with a wang and drives
away the following morning on the third
day of their Journey the team arrives at
junai Lake where they are greeted by a
distressing scene over 400 bloodied
carcasses of freshly skinned Antelope
lying on the ground they then summon
some fishermen fishing in the nearby
frozen lake and ask if they saw any
poachers in response they affirm
claiming that they were a few but the
darkness prevented them from seeing
their faces as they interrogate them
raii figures out that those fishermen
also don't possess fishing licenses so
he makes them pay the penalty fee after
this the patrol officers dig up a hole
drag the corpses into it and burn them
all down guou is unable to muster enough
courage to photograph such a gruesome
sight with his camera the patrolling
team continues on their poacher hunting
journey and arrives at Yak Valley on the
fifth day on their way the poachers
suddenly launch fire towards their
vehicles causing one of the team members
to be severely wounded they instantly
apply first aid to his wound and
cautiously look around for their as
salance however they find no one but a
Jeep probably belonging to the poacher
after a brief inspection of the vehicle
they resort to burning it down after
driving for several more days they come
across the Kumar River where they spot a
bunch of poachers across the river the
patrolling team hurriedly gets off their
vehicle takes off their pants and
crosses the river to apprehend the
hunters can't fight Hunters unless we're
pantsless you know they soon figure out
that the poachers group is led by an
elderly man named ma Jan ly and his son
Chang they then take Chang away from the
group in order to talk to him in private
for the first few minutes the guy claims
that he is just a driver and knows
nothing about the gunman but when the
officers threaten him with their gun he
finally agrees to comply revealing that
he is not the Mastermind behind all of
this there is someone else in addition
he also discloses the whereabouts of the
Hidden skin upon arriving at the exact
location they Unearthed several bags
filled with Antelope skin while the team
members take out these bags reai is
furious as they are losing more
antelopes during the breeding season
following this all the apprehended
poachers as well as the retrieved Skins
are loaded into their vehicle after
which they continue heading forward to
apprehend the main boss after several
more hours of driving they stop in the
middle of a vast plain land and set up a
small tent in the midst of the
preparations guou gazes at the beautiful
stars that constellation looks just like
an antelope he is then approached by one
of the team members dawa the two
initiate a conversation and dawa tells
him that Kiki zili means beautiful
mountain woman in their native Tibetan
tongue he also expresses how he suffers
from homesickness every time he comes
for the patrolling Mission and how the
lights on the roads remind him of his
home later on everybody goes to sleep
while some patrolling officers stand
guard the following morning Rai wakes up
to find out that Maan Lin and Shang have
escaped from the tent this infuriates
him and EV vents his anger on the guards
who seem to have fallen asleep at 5:00
a.m. assuming that the poachers haven't
gotten too far the team sets off to find
them soon after they locate them running
in the distance so Rai accompanied by
two other patrolling officers chases
them through the vast Hills due to the
high altitude of Kiki zili the air is
very thin which results in them
struggling for breath despite the
setback the officers somehow managed to
catch the poachers but dawa collapses
during the process seeing this Rai
hurriedly approaches him and tries to
perform CPR but to no avail at this
critical point the apprehended Chang who
is a vet by profession volunteers to
help he then fills some kind of drugs in
an injection and administers it into
dawa's body ultimately bringing him back
to life in the aftermath of this
incident Rai instructs one of his team
members Leu dong to drive dawa to the
hospital he also hands him some cash for
the medical fees but it is not
sufficient left with no other choice Rai
tells him to sell some of the antelope
skins and raise the necessary money
after this Liu bids an emotional goodbye
to his friends and drives away with the
injured dawa just as they leave one of
the team members approaches Rai with the
bad news that they do not have enough
food for all of them when asked about
its details he asserts that the food
will last less than 2 days even if they
exclude the prisoners adding to their
challenges the driver discloses is that
they are running out of fuel as well and
that they can travel for a maximum of 4
days if they give up one of their trucks
upon hearing these reports Rai
comprehends the situation for a while
and eventually comes to a decision to
abandon the prisoners and go for their
boss Rai then releases all the prisoners
from their handcuffs and announces his
decision to abandon them also explaining
the reason why he is doing so he further
informs them that it is 200 km to the AL
mountain and 100 more to the konon pass
they can make their own choice and go
wherever they want Maan Lin requests to
be taken along because he is old and
frail however Rai can do nothing but
encourage the old man to not lose hope
after this the patrolling team continues
their journey ahead in two vehicles
theine then cuts to the 12th day of the
mission and rai's team are still on
their way at one point one of their
vehicles abruptly comes to a stop upon
inspection they learn that its engine
has been damaged and that it can't can't
be repaired Rai who is still not ready
to give up on his mission asks the three
of his team members to stay there and
wait for Liu's return while he along
with the rest of the team resumes their
Journey on their way guou asks Rai about
how they can reach their destination
without enough supplies in response Rai
shares his decision to sell the antelope
skins that they have when the report
mentions that it's illegal Rai asserts
that they've no other choice and that he
prefers to go to jail rather than
endangering his team members lives
elsewhere Maan Lin's team are seen
walking through the plains under the
worst weather conditions on their way
they are hit by a strong snowstorm that
claims the lives of some members
meanwhile The Continuous snowfall drops
the temperature so low that it becomes
tough for rai's stranded group to stay
there after waiting for a few days they
opt to trekk their way home rather than
waiting for help on the other hand Leu
drives day and night as fast as he can
because he does not have any food or
water every time he gets thirsty or
sleepy he gets out of the car and washes
his face with ice also consuming it
instead of water after 3 days of
Non-Stop and extremely exhausting
driving they finally reach a local
hospital Leu immediately gets off the
vehicle but he has no energy to walk so
he bangs on the vehicle's door to summon
the doctor following this the injured
dawa gets the necessary treatment while
Leu feels good after several hours of
proper rest later that night he meets
his girlfriend langu at a local bar
where she works the pair then drive to a
secluded location where they make out
inside the vehicle thank God this
Antelope movie was lacking sex appeal
after this Leu requests her to lend him
some money as he again has to return to
rescue his fellow crew members hearing
this Lang is upset with his risky and
unpredictable job and she can't bear how
he vanishes for days without any
information
as a result she decides to help him for
the last time and end the relationship
forever M the antelopes babe and I know
you love the antelopes the next morning
Leu successfully sells the remaining
Antelope skins and gathers enough money
to buy all the essential supplies once
he fills up the vehicle with them he
makes his way back to rejoin his team
members during his non-stop drive his
vehicle unfortunately gets stuck in the
sand in an attempt to get it out Leu
starts unloading the supplies from the
vehicles in this process he himself gets
trapped in the dry quicksand that slowly
pulls him downward he desperately tries
to get out of it but his movements only
worsen the situation after numerous
failed attempts he ultimately accepts
his fate and allows the sand to engulf
him completely on the 17th day of the
mission rai's vehicle runs out of fuel
prompting the team to continue the rest
of their Journey on foot Rai and guou
walk forward while exhaustion causes the
rest of the team to lag behind after
hours of walking the two come across the
main boss and his accompli despite being
outnumbered and outgunned Rai orders the
boss to surrender himself and come along
with him instead of complying with his
orders the criminal boss tries to bribe
him with two vehicles and a new house
for his family what is this guy anel
opra however the Brave and ethical reti
is unswayed by his offer and resorts to
fighting them unfortunately the
patrolling Captain is fatally shot by
the enemies while guou is let free as
he's just a reporter in the next scene
rai's body is brought back home and is
prepared for a sky burial the movie ends
with captions stating that gu's reports
on the atrocities in kiili had a
profound impact on the country a year
later the Chinese government declared
kiili a national Nature Preserve and
established a forestry Bureau to
safeguard it the captions further
indicate that antelope numbers increased
to 30,000 by the time of the film's
release subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching